- I mean, one, I
mean, obviously,
there are certain people
in the Biden Administration
who should be impeached, right?
Mayorkas-
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Has clearly violated
his oath of office.
I think Garland has
violated his oath of office.
I don't know if
any of these guys
have done something
criminal, but certainly,
if you reveal
something criminal,
even if you're a very
powerful official, maybe,
especially if you're
a powerful official,
you should suffer criminal
consequences because of it.
(mellow music)
- All right, it's day three of
three here in Washington, DC.
I'm still Dave Rubin. This
is still "The Rubin Report."
And joining me today is the
junior senator from Ohio
and the new guy in this
crazy town, JD Vance.
Welcome back to
"The Rubin Report."
- Thanks, Dave. How are you?
- Good. First time we've
sat down in person.
We've done this
digitally a couple times.
- Sure.
- You are the new guy in town.
How they treating you, man?
- You know, it's not too
bad. I'm having a good time.
And the thing I've learned
about DC is that, I mean, yeah,
it is the swamp and yeah, the
crime rate is outta control.
You saw, of course,
the news that happened
with Rand Paul's staffer,
which is just awful.
And thank God he's
gonna be okay.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- The work of the Senate,
despite the fact that
Republicans are in the minority,
still actually proceeds at pace,
and we're able to
get some things done.
We've killed a couple of
very bad Biden
Administration nominees.
You know, we've gotten
some good legislation,
I think, starting
to move through the
congressional process.
Biden would probably
veto a lot of it,
but we're at least
getting some things done.
And at the very least,
we'll force Biden to answer
for some of his veto decisions
over the next couple years.
- Do you feel like
a politician now?
Because for people
that know you,
and we'll link to the original
interview, so they can-
- Yeah.
- If they don't know, they
can check out your bio.
I mean, you are clearly not-
- Sure.
- What a general
politician is thought of.
- Yeah, no, not at all.
I don't feel like a politician.
I mean, eventually,
I assume that I will,
or at least I'll have to
start saying I'm a politician.
I mean, once you run for office-
- You have staff
members, so I guess-
- 30 staff members, so, yeah,
eventually, you start to
feel like a politician.
But no, I mean, I
guess I still feel
the sense of awe
about it, right?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- It's very easy, I think,
especially when
you're conservative
and you're just so frustrated
with what happens in DC,
it's very easy to get cynical
about politics at large.
But when you walk through the
halls of Congress and you see,
you know, oh, there's
John F Kennedy's desk,
there's Richard Nixon's desk,
and you realize that a lot
of the great and bad moments
of American history
happened, which,
in what is your new office,
it's hard not to feel
some sense of awe at it,
and I think that when
you're a politician,
you probably don't
feel that at all.
You feel just entitled to it.
I hope that never happens to me.
- Yeah. That's gonna
be the trick, right?
- Yeah.
- To make sure that
it never gets old.
So, one of the things
that I've been saying
for a couple months is that
I sense the Republicans
maybe starting to
do the right thing.
- Sure.
- It feels like it's happening.
I sat down with
McCarthy yesterday.
He laid out an actual agenda.
- [JD] Yeah.
- I sense from all the
guys that I'm talking to,
the guys and gals that I'm
talking to in the Senate,
Congress, that it might
actually be happening.
Do you believe that
the Republicans can
get something done
and that the never ending
swamp and deep state
and all that just won't
expand and eat you all up
and all of that?
- Yeah, I mean, I feel
optimistic about it,
but it's gonna
require some more work
and some more progress.
I think, obviously,
the guys in the House,
because they have
the gavels, right?
They have the majority.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- They have
investigatory powers.
I think we're gonna learn
a lot about what's gone on
with the Department of Justice.
I think we're gonna
learn a lot about
why the attorney general is
harassing political opponents
instead of doing the
job of law enforcement.
I think we may even
see some consequences
for some of the people who
have done some things wrong.
- What would that
look like to you?
'Cause I've been asking
everybody about that,
that we do the hearings.
- Yeah.
- We find out people
lie under oath
and sort of nothing happens.
What would consequences
actually look like?
- You know, I mean,
one, I mean, obviously,
there are certain people
in the Biden Administration
should be impeached, right?
Mayorkas.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Has clearly violated
his oath of office.
I think Garland has
violated his oath of office.
I don't know if
any of these guys
have done something criminal,
but certainly, if you
reveal something criminal,
even if you're a very
powerful official,
maybe especially if you're
a powerful official,
you should suffer criminal
consequences because of it.
But I think even just
knowing what's going on
is a big part of
the equation here,
and we still have no
idea behind the scenes
what's really gone on.
You know, just take
one example, right?
When the Department of
Justice was harassing parents
who were peacefully
protesting last year,
critical race theory being
taught in their schools,
what decision was made?
Who made it? Was it motivated
by political persecution?
Was it just an innocent,
albeit terrible mistake?
Knowing the answers to
these questions is something
the American people have
been totally closed off of.
- So that's where you say,
if Garland wrote it himself,
and I guess it's
maybe a little unclear
who actually wrote
the memo that that-
- It's unclear who
wrote the memo.
It's unclear who directed
it, but yeah, I mean,
if you're the attorney
general and you're sicking
your law enforcement
officials after parents
for peacefully protesting,
that, to me, is a criminal act.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Right, you have to suffer
consequences for that.
But, you know, we'll see.
And that's one of
the good things.
I think dismantling some
of these bureaucracies
is a really core part of this.
I do think that you're gonna see
in the debt ceiling
negotiation, this is, you know,
my colleagues in the House,
they really have a pin on this,
but I think it would look
like really defunding
some of the more woke
sides of the bureaucracy.
And I hate to say it.
That includes the
Department of Defense.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Where you have a lot
of the senior leadership,
not the troops, but
the senior leadership
of the Department of
Defense has gone really in
for a progressive social agenda.
- Do you believe that there's
really a chance to do that?
- Yeah, I do.
- I mean, this is one
that you've hit hard
how it's affected our
military specifically.
- This one in particular,
I do think that's it's possible
because here's the thing,
A lot of these ridiculous
DEI bureaucracies
within the federal government,
they cost money, okay?
And so, the debt
ceiling negotiation
is a perfect opportunity
for us to say,
look, we're not gonna
fund these things.
It's good policy. It's
also good budgetary sense.
And so, yeah, I do think
there's some chance of progress.
Do I think we're gonna get
everything? No, of course not.
Right, I'm a realist,
but I do think that we're gonna
be in a much better position
with a much less well
funded DEI bureaucracy
in the federal government.
- So, I wanna get to
some specific stuff
that you're doing.
- Sure.
- And obviously East
Palestinian especially,
but one more generally.
I told you right
before we sat down
that I'm sitting down
with about 20 Republicans.
We finally got one Democrat
to at least respond to us,
but of course it was a no,
but 19 or so did not
even respond at all.
- Sure.
- You mentioned one guy who
maybe we could sit down,
I don't know if he's even
want his name mentioned
right here, but how's
that going for you?
Are you able to find some
Democrats that you can work with
and talk to and
that sort of thing?
- Yeah, you know, absolutely.
The way that I put it is that
there are specific issues
where you can find some
Democrats that you agree with.
You know, on the energy
issue, for example, I think,
you know, some of the
folks in West Virginia
are not so supportive of Joe
Manchin being anti-energy.
So, we can maybe apply some
pressure to permitting reform.
We happen to think,
by the way, Dave,
that the main reason
why we have inflation
is an energy supply issue.
We really destroyed the
American base of energy.
I think that's as important
as all of the other drivers
of inflation, maybe the
single most important issue,
so, yeah-
- What I keep asking
everybody, is,
is it intentional or is it
ineptitude, do you think?
- You know, man, it's
a very good question.
I don't have a good answer yet.
I tend, my bias is always,
never assume malice or stupidity
is a good enough explanation.
I do think you have
some pretty dark figures
within the Biden Administration
who are doing a
lot of bad things.
But I think the way that
they have so much power
is probably incompetence
rather than malice
in the senior officials.
But I don't know, right?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Part of the reason
why these investigations
are so important is
we need to understand
what's driving, what motivates
the senior leadership
of the federal government.
- Yeah. All right, so let's
get into some of the specifics.
- Yeah.
- That you're dealing with.
So, obviously East Palestine.
So, this accident happens.
- Sure.
- And then really nobody
outside of Ohio, and then,
you know, a couple
people on Twitter,
I guess, were talking about
it for the first 10 days.
- Yeah.
- Then finally it bubbled up.
- Sure.
- People started
talking about it.
You obviously were
down there and showing
what's going on with
the water and all that.
But now, two weeks later
or three weeks later,
we're not talking
about it again.
- [JD] Yeah.
- So, I guess give me an update
and how bad was the
response by this government?
- Yeah. So this is
a big risk, right?
As people forget about it,
the politicians and the
cameras stop showing up,
and so, everyone goes home.
And that would be really
bad for the people
of East Palestine.
By the way, that's what
they're terrified of, right,
is they're gonna be forgotten.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- There are a few
different things going on.
So in the initial
stages of the cleanup,
both the Biden Administration
and Norfolk Southern
almost couldn't be bothered
to do the things they needed.
Norfolk Southern is
the train company.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- That caused the crash.
It's like whack-a-mole.
What I found over the past
eight weeks is every two weeks,
it's something new.
So, five weeks ago,
I would've told you,
Norfolk Southern needs
to get off its rear-end
and actually get
this cleanup finished
because they bear
responsibility for it.
Three weeks ago, I would've
told you that the EPA
was making it harder
for Norfolk Southern.
Norfolk Southern was starting
to do what they needed to do,
but the EPA was making
it harder for them.
And that's kind of been
the way that our office
has approached it is,
look, each problem,
let's just try to solve
each discreet problem
because that's the
job of a senator,
is to solve problems
for your constituents.
What I worry about
over the next,
two big things
that I worry about
for the people of
East Palestine.
Number one is we have to provide
the long-term health
screening, right?
When you talk to people
in East Palestine,
they're not worried
they drink the water
and they're gonna
drop dead tomorrow.
They're worried their grandkids
are gonna drink the water-
- [Dave] Yeah.
- For 10 years.
- And develop a
rare form of cancer.
There is no bureaucracy.
There's no, this is crazy to me,
something I didn't
know a month ago.
There is no apparatus within
the federal government,
all of the CDC and public
health bureaucracy,
to test for chronic
exposure to pollutants.
We just don't have
that capability
in the federal
government right now.
And so, we're trying to-
- What is it that the EPA
does then, if not test water
that's almost glowing when
you put a stick in it?
- Well, they test it.
Their argument is they test
for acute toxins, right?
They can tell you
whether, you know,
you're gonna drink this
water and there are toxins
at a level that are gonna
cause sickness the next day.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- They have no real apparatus
test for chronic exposure.
And that's the big problem here.
So, number one is
you've gotta do the long
term health screening
for the people of
East Palestine.
And again, they're terrified
they're gonna be forgotten.
Here's the other
crazy thing, Dave.
So, imagine you're a
farmer in East Palestine.
You grow chickens. You
sell farm fresh eggs.
You sell hay.
Does anybody wanna
buy your stuff?
- [Dave] Right, right.
- If you're in East Palestine?
What about if you
paid off your house?
You've been living there for
40 years and the home value
is fallen through
the roof by 50%?
So, we're gonna have to deal
with the economic devastation
of this.
And I hate to say it, Dave.
I think the Biden
Administration doesn't care
about this issue
because they know
the people of East Palestinian
are not their voters,
and we have to make them care.
And that's one of the
things I have to focus on,
not just for the next few
weeks, but the next few months.
- Doesn't it really suck to
believe that, that you'd want-
- Yeah, it does.
- Like, Trump goes down there,
and to me, that's
Trump at his best.
- Absolutely.
- It's like no nonsense.
He's there for the people.
He gave away stuff.
He even brought attention to it.
Can you contrast that with
then about three days later,
then, Pete Buttigieg shows up.
I suspect the reaction was
a little bit different.
- He looks like a, he
looked like my toddler,
sort of the hard hat dress up.
- Right, right, right.
- That was my initial
reaction when I saw him.
I guess, you know,
just partially, he's
a young looking guy.
- I'm surprised they
didn't have him on the bike
going into town there.
- Just that.
But the crazy thing is the
complete lack of earnestness
or urgency from the
president of United States.
I can't think of, if this,
I really don't believe if this
had happened in a community
with a Democratic
interest group,
that you would've had
complete ignorance,
complete refusal to show up,
to show any real leadership
for the Biden Administration.
But that's really
what we've seen.
And I hate to say it, but I
do think that the, you know,
whether it's Biden himself or
the people who work for him,
you never know with Joe Biden,
whether it's actually him,
you know, who's
driving the wheel.
None of us actually know.
But the problem is they have
this friend enemy distinction
in politics,
and you've really
seen this with the way
they've gone after
political opponents.
But if you're not
on the right side
of their political ledger,
they don't feel like they
have an obligation to you.
I think it's a
complete inversion
of constitutional
government in our country,
but it's unfortunately
what we've seen a lot
for the past couple years.
- Yeah, as I'm sure you know.
I mean, yesterday was, was it
yesterday or the day before?
Matt Taibbi was testifying
about government overreach.
- Yes.
- And the IRS literally
showed up at his house
during the hearing.
- Absolutely.
- I mean-
- Just crazy.
- This is weird.
- Yeah, I mean, it's weird.
It really is banana
republic stuff, right?
- Yeah.
- That gets thrown around
too much, but, you know,
if you're Matt
Taibbi, I don't know.
- And he's a lefty. I
mean, that's the point.
- Yeah, he's a lefty,
but, of course,
he's said things that are
offensive to the Biden regime.
- Yeah.
- And I use that
word specifically.
I do think it's a bit
of a regime, but look,
you have agents of
the government showing
up at your house
who have subpoena
power over you,
have the power to take your
money away, and that is,
that happens when
you dare speak up
against government authority?
That is not the United
States of America.
But again, it is what
we're seeing a lot
from the Biden Administration.
And it's not just that.
I mean, you see it with
pro-life activists.
I mean, we could go through
the number of examples
where the Biden Administration
just conveniently,
just coincidentally,
happens to send
government agents
against their
political opposition,
but it happens so frequently
that I don't think many people
who are paying
attention are blind
to what's actually going on.
- So we have somewhat
limited time here.
- Yeah.
- So let's just do a
couple of other ones
that you're talking a lot about.
Let's, Ukraine, Russia,
I don't know that we can
do somewhat quickly, but-
- [JD] Sure.
- But I think your
basic position is, hey,
we're endlessly
funding something
that there's no endgame here.
- [JD] Yeah.
- Is that pretty much the
simplest version of it?
- There's no end game
and nobody's articulated
what we're actually
trying to accomplish.
If you really ask the people
who are driving our
Russia, Ukraine policy,
what are we trying to do,
nobody can actually tell you.
I think it's really telling,
by the way, you know,
I've endorsed President Trump,
but it's really telling to
me that both President Trump
and Ron DeSantis, the
two clear front runners
for the Republican nomination,
nobody else has
really any chance,
both of them are saying,
we need to be a little
bit more cautious
about our Russia,
Ukraine policy.
And yet the entire
establishment in Washington
has taken the opposite view.
I think it's a terrible mistake,
but let me sort of make one
very important point here.
The argument that I make
about Russia, Ukraine
is that there is a clear
conflict between our interests
in East Asia and our
interests in Eastern Europe.
So, if we wanna prevent the
Chinese from invading Taiwan,
cutting off access
to semiconductors,
tanking our economy,
making it possible
for us to manufacture
modern weapons of war,
that's what an invasion
of Taiwan would do.
We need to focus on East Asia.
Weapons that we are
sending to Ukraine
mean weapons that we
cannot send to Taiwan.
And because America
doesn't manufacture
enough of its own artillery,
enough of its own missiles,
there is a clear conflict.
It's not, it is unfortunately
a zero sum dynamic.
The more we focus on Ukraine,
the more empowered
China is in East Asia.
And anybody who
ignores that reality
is not being serious
about the trade offs.
- All right.
Unfortunately, we only
have time for one more,
so I'll let you choose it.
We can either do ESG, big
tech or border and fentanyl,
which obviously I
know is big with you.
- Let's do big tech.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- So, big tech, I mean, are
we gonna fix any of this?
Elon obviously is at least
loosening some of it,
and we're getting a
little more info, but?
- Yeah, so this is another
area where I actually,
you know, this is
one of the few places
where there are enough Democrats
where you might
actually be doing it,
be able to do something
big here in the Senate.
On the House side, I think
that they're, you know,
they're going in
interesting directions, too.
But you know, to me,
I continue to believe
that we have to think about
this as an antitrust problem.
The technology companies are
individually too powerful
within their markets, and
what they have ended up doing
is imposing this ideological
regime from the top down.
And look, this is
a little bit weird,
I think, for a lot
of conservatives.
- [Dave] Yep.
- A lot of people who believe
in the free market, right?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- They say, well, these
are private companies.
And my counter argument to
that, Dave, is always, well,
they're private companies,
but they've achieved
their market power
through an unbelievable
accumulation of
government favors,
of illegal carve outs,
of liability protections.
So these are behemoths created
by the power of the
US federal government,
and I think they can
only be curtailed
by the power of the
US federal government.
So, I really think
that the, you know,
we need to go into
trust buster mode,
break up some of
these companies, make
them less powerful.
Some of this, even the
threat of antitrust,
I think, is making these
companies less ideological
and less progressive.
Obviously Twitter is a, I
think, a really good thing.
I think what Elon did
is frankly heroic.
But you still have Facebook.
You still have Google,
which is probably the
single biggest problem.
I think the threat of action
is making these companies
a little bit less crazy,
but I think real action
would restore some sanity
to our process.
One thing, and I know we're
a little short on time here,
but one quick thing on this.
So, the way that Google
is most powerful,
you maybe have heard this,
so stop me if you had,
is it really biases-
- Other people are watching
this too, so, it's okay.
- Okay. Sure.
But it really
biases fundraising-
- [Dave] Yeah.
- To Democrats over Republicans.
- So if you look at
the way that Gmail
filters Republican
fundraising emails-
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Versus Democratic
fundraising emails.
I just went through
a campaign, man.
That's how you pay for
the TV advertisements
that reach the middle
of the road voters
that every person needs,
even in a deep red state.
So, if Google is biasing
their own email client-
- [Dave] Yep.
- To left wing activists,
that's gonna have
major ramifications
for our political system.
I think it already has.
I think it's one of
the reasons, frankly,
Blake lost in Arizona.
I think it's one of
the reasons Herschel
didn't do as well in Georgia
is because the
massive fundraising
advantage the left has.
If you don't fix that problem,
you can't send good
people to Washington.
The best you're
gonna get is frankly
establishment blow hards
who don't do anything.
The worse you're gonna
get is far left Democrats.
To actually have a real
America first movement,
you have to solve the big
tech fundraising problem.
- All right. This
was somewhat brief.
- Okay.
- But we'll do it again.
- Absolutely.
- And my challenge to
you always will be that
you gotta still be excited
when you walk in there.
- Yeah.
- Because I can sense a
lot of the people aren't,
and that is part
of the problem, so.
- Yeah, agreed. Thanks, Dave.
Good to see you, man.
- Yeah.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.